uh oh the USDA has predicted a turkey
shortage this year Christians many
Southern nevadans begin to prep for the
holiday feast now some are scrambling to
find one and bracing to spend a little
more as inflation is driving up the
price
the clock is ticking to get the bird and
all the Thanksgiving Fixins bean
casserole
one of my favorites and I also like
besides turkey I like my ham but this
year having the turkey on your table
will cost you more and you could be
competing with others on finding one for
the right price so far all we have is
one turkey breast we have the makings
for our jellos and our stuffing and
baked potatoes Amazon Fresh it was only
thirty dollars and I just checked
yesterday they still have some in stock
pretty early though you gotta shop early
the USDA alerting consumers of a
possible turkey shortage this year and
early next year due to an outbreak of
Avian Influenza the last outbreak was in
2015 where according to the USDA about
50 million birds were affected so we're
trying to order a lot at one time so we
can make sure that we have them during
Thanksgiving but even right now we're
still waiting on turkey legs and whole
turkeys Joseph Adams runs his Las Vegas
business on Saharan Decatur that
specializes in turkey dishes with the
bird shortage he's concerned about
keeping up with demand this is called
stuff by turkey not stuffed my chicken
so we have to have turkey legs in our
restaurant so right now we're hoping
that everybody will catch up and we'll
be able to get those supplies in like
everything else inflation is causing
prices to go up including turkeys
jumping about 115 per pound last year to
1 147 this year according to the USDA is
that at all going to impact you guys no
because we're going to do it anyway
all right so we checked some ads from
popular grocery stores across the valley
and this is what we found Smith's has
turkeys for 79 cents a pound limit one
and you need to make a 25 purchase to
get that deal also a digital deal from
bonds and Albertsons a dollar forty
seven also Walmart we should add has
some various deals with the lowest price
at 98 cents a pound